We have to talk about
composition of your images
but it's very
difficult to separate
the idea of composition and
point of view, background.
And even lighting,
they all go together.
When you adjust your light
-- you'll see later --
you're going to get a different
kind of shadow and that shadow
becomes part of the composition.
So, we've attempted to separate
them into three categories,
but really they are
very closely connected
and it's something
to keep in mind.
So let's start with these
leaves, these autumn
leaves that I put on a light
box, which you will see more
of when we talk about light.
In fact the light box itself
is an important compositional
element in this
image because it's
giving us a very strong negative
space between the leaves.
And, it could be an
interesting thing
to play around with, using
the background as part
of your composition.
Something to think about.
Taking a look at these
crystals, which I just randomly
placed on a background just to
show the ability of creating
these crystals.
Uh, this is, you
know, an okay image.
Um, by the way, notice how
the shadows of these crystals
become part of the composition.
What I finally decided to
do was, simplify the image
and just selected four
crystals and made a more close,
close-up shot of them.
They're both fine and and
that's one of these issues about
what's better.
I mean, we could
split hairs and --
I really don't think there's
any...we could argue either
way.
That's the fun part about this.
Once again, there are no
rules to any of these things.
One of my gut ideas, which has
no data associated with it is I
think it's more interesting
to show two of something
rather than show one.
And I suppose that I could
speak to some psychologist
and discuss whether we
really do perceive it more.
I don't know, I just,
it's just the way I do it.
And I'm suggesting that if
you like what I do, then maybe
you'll wanna do it, too.
I did take these two
devices (by the way,
it does show that you
can do more than one,
you can create more than one)
and I photographed it this way.
I photographed it in my
studio with a skylight above.
And notice there is a little
problem with depth of field.
The one above is not really
as sharp as it should be.
And so I stopped down, which
you know, that what that means,
so that the aperture
became smaller
and I gave myself
more depth of field.
That is I got more in focus.
And what [laughing]
happened was,
I got so much in focus
that I could actually
see the detail of the skylight
with the clouds showing
through.
This is tangential to the
point, but it's all connected
and you have to really pay
attention and learn to see
what it is you're getting at.
Eventually, I would up, I
thought that this next image
was the best.
Again, using two and
not necessarily showing
exactly the edge
of each, I think
it's an interesting idea to not
completely finish the image.
Let the viewer finish it in more
of a participatory involvement,
perhaps.
ONCE AGAIN THIS
IDEA OF TWOS: Here
are two balls that
have so small a pattern
that we're seeing
light refracting.
And here are two
silicon chips that
have material embedded on it.
Again, I decided
to do it in twos.
Here's another two
duet, two petri dishes
of E. Coli growing.
By the way, notice the
composition: It's not
exactly equal, equally divided.
I have one a little
more than the other.
For our book, No
Small Matter, we
wanted to talk
about self-assembly.
Actually these are two acrylic
dishes with acrylic balls
that literally
line themselves up
and I did it in twos as well.
You know, again, it's an idea
that I'm comfortable with.
It's actually easier to compose
when you have two things.
At least it is for me.
You might give it a shot.
You might think of using
the process of composing
your picture as means of telling
a story, a visual story of what
your devices are about.
What you're seeing here,
you're seeing basically three
components of an image.
You're seeing the underside
of a wafer on your upper left,
the green upper left.
And that wafer has
fabricated on it small chips.
So the fuchsia color is what
the wafer looks like as a whole.
And then we we have
the individual chips
on top of the larger wafer.
So you'll see the
individual ones as well.
So trying to sort of say
this is a fabrication
of these particular
chips that deliver drugs.
That's why we wanted to show
the underside of the wafer.
By the way, all this needs
to be discussed in a caption.
None of this works
without text, but uh this
is an attempt to visually
describe what this is.
In this next one,
these are fibers
that are constructed
so that they have
different optical qualities.
And the attempt was, I tried to
weave them in sort of a [laugh]
fabric because that's
what they were thinking
of making it work with.
They were imagining these
fibers literally being
woven into clothing.
I don't know if
it ever happened,
but this is a
number of years ago.
Once again telling, suggesting
the use of material.
In this next one I was
just playing around with,
this was trying to show glass
when it's treated properly.
You see on the upper
right and the lower right
when glass is treated in
a certain way it shatters
properly and safety wise whereas
the other one in the more
triangular area, it's just
not the way that we wanted.
It is a little too artsy
probably or many of you,
but again, I was
just playing and I
do want you, as I
continue saying,
to play with this stuff.
The next one it
was about corn that
was treated in a
particular way and I
decided to use the containers,
the plastic material that it
came in as a suggestion of
how these are delivered.
And finally, just some devices
that evolved over time.
These are various iterations
of a particular idea
and we see how they
changed, how they
evolved, telling a
sort of chronology
of these particular devices.
This is an example of really
stretching our imagination.
It's of the watch that we've
seen before on my computer
screen as well, which
I have focused in on
and we're seeing a
detail of the watch.
Using the computer screen
as another light source
but a compositional one as well.
So here I'm selecting the image
of the watch on the screen.
I don't like the colors here.
That's what we're
doing here, we're
basically going to be
matching the colors.
So I selected the watch
then inverted, selected
the real watch, as
opposed to the screen,
and now we have an image
that is balanced, color-wise.
Just imagine, perhaps, another
kind of image on your screen
with your device.
Maybe to expand the explanation
of how your image works.
Something you might
want to think of,
using your own imagination.
So this is just a
hint [laugh] of what
you could do with composition.
And, as I said before,
it's very difficult
to separate this
idea of composition
with point of view
and backgrounds,
which you'll see
in very shortly.
So, you know, it's
all connected and I
could have very easily put some
of these in other categories,
but thought it would be
fun to just try for myself,
by the way, in separating
them, but they are truly
very much connected.